دراما سيري نظريه الدراما
تعودنا عليها في المسرح السينما والاعمال
الفنيه والروائيه اذا كان العمل مكتوب
مخصوص للمسرح حول الشاشه او ان وقتها او
انه هدفتيشن او تحويل من روايه
وبين الاعمال التسجيليه اللي هي تكون اكثر
وفاء ال ال ال التاريخ احنا امام امام
حاجه ثالثه جديده
واقول جديده لان انا بعد يمكن مرور 50 60
70 كمان 100 سنه حقيقي نقاط ويضعوا ربما
بعد المقاييس النقديه لانها لازال جديده
انا اتكلمنا عن طلب بن شداد
النصر صلاح الدين وما الى ذلك يوسف شاهين
نفسه الله يرحمه كان صديقي
كان هو قال لي ان هذه الاعمال ما كانش
راضي عليها هذه الاعمال لما رجعوه ولما
جمال عبد الناصر طبعا هربت
اليسار المصري دخل السجن وفي ناس هربت
وراح بيروت
رئيس جمال عبد الناصر
يعني فكان هو ملتزم
بصياغه تاريخيه غير واقعيه ولكنها تلائم
النظريه النظام في مصر كان بيحاول يحطها
وكان بيك عنده ابتدا بقى فكره يضم
الولايات العثمانيه السابقه في ما يسمى بي
الوحده العربيه وما لا ذلك وبالتالي كان
بيضحها بنحاول انه يصرخ الماضي على الحاضر
في حين عمل يوسف شاهين نفسه كادرامي اذا
نظرنا مثلا همم حسب الاستاذ نظرنا الى باب
الحديد باب الحديد الله يرحمه الاستاذ عبد
الحي اديب كاتب السيناريو ده كان اول مره
في السنه سيناريو كتب خصيصا للشاشه مش
مقتبس من عمل ادبي او من مسرحيه عالميه
وجدنا ان رغم عمل دراما مباشر شخصيات
خارجيه لانها بتعالج مشاكل واقعيه وتعالج
مشكله المراه العامله اللي ما لهاش احد
كزوزه بيعامل مشكله الانسان اللي هو
مشوه لكنه مطحون والناس بتنبسه بيعامل
مساله الست بتاعه الحركه النسائيه والحركه
النقابيه اللي ليس لها علاقه بواقع الناس
رغم انه عمل درامي بقول لها شخصيات جديده
الا انها بتعاني مشاكل الواقع الانسان